for more on the impact of social
distancing CBS News chief medical
correspondent dr. Jon LaPook joins us
via Skype from his home in New York City
he is self-quarantine iing thereafter
possibly coming into contact with
someone who tested positive for kovat 19
more and more people are in that
situation these days good morning dr.
LaPook morning Tony we are dealing with
these very dizzying changes in in
everyday life the restrictions and
advisories have gone from don't go to
Italy now to don't go to your corner bar
and don't gather in groups of more than
10 all in the name of social distancing
how much of a benefit do we expect to
get from social distancing I think there
could be a very big benefit and I will
tell you why we talked about again this
flattening of the curve it early on with
an epidemic you get this big peak with
that big peak big load on the healthcare
system you can have shortages of health
care professionals and supplies as
you're hearing does it work if we can
blunt that if we can blunt that curb and
flatten it out and instead of having one
big spike spread them out a little bit
it may last a little longer but you
won't have that big load at that point
does it work yeah we're seeing in China
and South Korea elsewhere
these kind of efforts make a difference
and we're seeing a slowing of new cases
so yes it matters and especially people
who are young you you heard president
Trump talk about the young and the
healthy it's important for them also
even though they may be relatively
spared from the severe effects of kovat
19 they can spread it to others so we're
hearing reports of young people out in
the streets are still you know doing the
normal gathering and don't do that
because you you may bring it a
symptomatically without symptoms or with
minimal symptoms and in fact your mother
your grandmother etcetera so everybody
has to be responsible here yeah that's
why they said Millennials are the key to
spreading this John what about play
dates for your kids is that a good idea
is that okay you know you have to think
of of course with kids when you have you
know kids are mingling there's no way
you're gonna say to them listen stay six
feet apart and COFF into the crook of
your arm right you have to assume you're
mingling germs with kids then you have
to think of what are their contacts so
if you're with a child your child is
with a child who's in contact with them
is there somebody in that family who's
at high risk high risk means somebody
with
medical condition serious medical
condition like high blood pressure heart
disease diabetes of course a weakened
immune system and then the question of
if they're with somebody who's elderly
now I've been trying to hunt this down
what's elderly yeah
Gail you may be like me elderly is
somebody at least 10 to 15 years older
than whatever whatever I exactly I
actually checked with the CDC they're
kind of like well you know 65 and above
but there's very good data here to look
at it in the current situation if you
look in Italy you see that the mortality
rate really spikes up from 70 to 79 and
above it's not like 69 you're fine at 71
you're not fine but I think that's a
good sort of idea gives you an idea of a
data point of what might be a time where
your risk really goes up all right dr.
John Pope thank you John